president Trump is driven much of the
mainstream media bonkers once again Fox
News is among a number of outlets that
confirmed a Washington Post report that
during an oval office meeting with
lawmakers on immigration today that when
we were just talking about Trump balked
at that deal and said and I substitute
one particular word here why are we
having all these people from blank whole
countries come here the president was
reportedly referring to the countries of
Haiti El Salvador and of course that's
the home of ms-13 mind you and some
African nations CNN completely freaked
out the president seems to harbor racist
feelings about people of color from
other parts of the world the president
has racist views I mean you know well
how long do we have to dance around that
that issue Jeffrey Toobin talking about
dancing is not something I ever want to
think about let's bring back an Coulter
and Mark Krikorian
and also welcome immigration attorney
Michael wilds in New York and let's go
to you on this issue of the black hole
countries because he said that Toobin
and Acosta go right to the same old
trope they tried in 2016 Donald Trump is
obvious obviously then harboring
ill-will toward people of color right
and don't change the channel from
Laura's show but this is the funnest
night to watch CNN since election night
it's fantastic that's not enough I do
still I do still want a wall so he's not
gonna win me back with just you know his
rhetoric again he said he's gonna build
wall a million times not until we
actually see the wall but you know I
think it's worth mentioning this is
exactly what all of the Democratic
sponsors of the 1965 Immigration Act
promised us Teddy Kennedy Bobby Kennedy
the Washington Post Emanuel Celler swore
up and down this immigration act will
not change the ethnic composition of
America we will not be overwhelmed by
immigrants from Asia from Africa from
the Caribbean from anyone Kahn
they swore up and down in fact the 1965
Immigration Act and their coats by the
way are all in Italian America they're
acted exactly the opposite of that
basically Western European immigration
was shut down we were overwhelmed with
the third world now if anybody complains
about it they call you a racist well no
we're just saying we can we hold was
Teddy Kennedy a racist for saying it
wouldn't do all of the things it did all
right no manifestly it's true we want
westerners who can speak english just
one thing on your you were talking about
how they don't have enough money for the
wall i was thinking when when you were
saying that you know as long as these
countries are such fantastic countries
maybe we could get you know cut off the
foreign aim to all of them and use that
for the wall our tax remittances are
shut down remittances to other countries
altogether i mean they sent twenty
billion dollars out of the country fifty
percent tax you get ten billion right
there michael i want to go to you on
this your reaction to the president's
reported comment well i first thank you
Laura for having me on again I I have to
say just for context I happen to have
been the president's immigration lawyer
for over ten years acting on behalf of
Trump models and Miss Universe and so
forth a staunch a Democrat I still
represent actually mrs. Trump I have to
tell you that I was disappointed by the
words and the tone I did not believe the
President to be a bigot I think this is
a contentious issue and a president
should be speaking in a presidential
capacity with better choice of words but
the fact is the dialogue has
deteriorated we have unfortunately
leaders in this nation in both houses
that have not done anything to fix this
broken immigration system it's festering
and you know family reunification was a
hallmark of the 1965 Act it's now been
given a derogatory term of chain
migration so we got a lot of things to
fix guys without interrupting let me
just say something we have 50,000
lottery visas and we have 10,000 people
getting EB fives where they put a
million dollars and buy green cards
effectively yes there are some things
that we need to do they want to drop
brothers and sisters and in exchange put
in a merit-based special visa for
intrapreneurs I'm all for you know
adding more venues to get illegal
immigrants I don't think we want
criminals in ms-13 here right well let
me get into the
because we promised our viewers we would
share some information tonight that we
uncovered today I was going around the
internet and I log on the Denver Post
websites an interesting website the
report on some cool issues that I care
about and crime is one of them and there
was a major heroin bust in Colorado this
week there's a 61 count indictment
against six individuals now we called
over and I guess we transferred a few
times around we found out that in
addition to the main suspect
Flores Rosales 47 year-old crystal ball
Flores Rosales Juan borkus Meza Mario
accosted Ruiz and you also to Campos and
Jose Torres Espinosa are all illegal
immigrants this was a $264,000 worth of
drugs including heroin we know what
heroin is doing to our youth we know
it's doing to our societies it is
poisoning them that's just one example
and that's why it matters because their
lives are affected and how many of these
kids could be daca recipients if they
hadn't been busted in a heroin ring
Michael they could receive daca amnesty
could they not Laurie get these
criminals out get this insidiousness the
oppressed Michael I complete my
innocence with know what Michael here's
what you could do you know again this
might work in your in your law practice
doesn't work with me these are
individuals who are taxing our police
our district attorneys our government
services if they're criminals that
cannot valedictorians right Michael
marker for him they shouldn't be in this
country and they never should be here is
it can occupy criminals because how many
didn't we catch there's two points on
the crime issue that are relevant here
you have the supporters of big
immigration say immigrants from the Adam
all together they're not that much more
likely or less likely to be criminals
than Americans when you add them all to
get
that might be true we don't know because
Han said the data doesn't exist they
don't collect it there are two points
that matter here one illegal immigrants
shouldn't be here so one crime is two
men one life one American life isn't
worth it
and immigrant communities even though
most of the people are perfectly
innocent they serve as kind of cover for
rings like this these guys were not
operating out in some suburban place
they were in another anecdote this is
very important this happened about ten
miles from Washington DC where we're
broadcasting from right now go back to
Valentine's Day of last year
female ms-13 gang member
17 years of age had another girl in her
grips and stabbed her multiple times
killing her she went on tape the
confession was taped and released to
local 5 News Fox 5 here in Washington
watch you need to tell me what you did
to her I killed her how did you kill her
she said to her also you'll see me again
in hell don't forget my name all
reported all admitted to another life
that shouldn't have been taken that
shouldn't have been this should never
have happened and you could take it away
here but I'm telling you any destruction
of life property rape shield child abuse
DWI why did the American people have to
tolerate this so liberals feel better
about themselves and their electoral
chances and to end Republicans get cheap
labor why right and they're not living
in those neighborhoods that happened
last year now that that was this year
this year ok so that's in Trump's
America so you know we do have if you
could flash back to trump promising that
the confession was just released the
killing happened in valentine's day of
last year yeah then Valentine's the
parents of the children murdered by
illegal aliens Trump set brought them up
on stage god bless him first time most
Americans have even heard of them and
said over and over again I won't forget
you I won't betray you
these killings going forward if Trump
does not keep his promises on
immigration by building a wall and
deporting illegals these are going to be
his cape stylee's now there now this is
on his record the next pulse nightclub
that's gonna be his and you better
remember the people who put them there
guys real quick Michael the dialogue has
deteriorated sadly where you're giving
the impression to everybody that most
foreigners or immigrants are criminals
and criminals and I'm telling you right
now scaring the hell out of America is
not a good title
Michael yeah what were your daughter's
to know what if that were your daughter
with with 12 knife wounds in her neck
what would you be saying we'd be coming
on the show saying oh the poor doc again
how dare you federal prosecutor I know
Corian just said that so don't tell me
Laura Laura Laura can I say something or
you want to talk or get a new
immigration lawyer we're out of time if
you're a former federal prosecutor youse
better you are wrong